we call you the bad boy we say that kind
of like jokingly but you do get into
fights and stuff a lot and have maybe I
don't know if it's fair to say like
maybe are angry at the world kind of I
just I was bullied my entire life
growing up really and I didn't realize
it was unnatural to have only a mom in
my household until like kids at school
were like making fun of me for is that
why they were bullying you well one of
the reasons but I was also overweight as
a kid so like my entire life I was just
bullied stepped on and it clicked in
high school like halfway through high
school that I just was tired of it I was
tired of people like stepping on me my
entire life yeah I guess it's like you
could say I have like an anger problem
but I mean I chilled out like a lot
right and now I I understand how stupid
altercations are you did a lot of
fighting growing up it sounds like yeah
yeah and when did you like lose the
weight halfway through High School how
much weight did you lose 40 pounds oh
wow that's significant yeah I was like
160 in seventh grade